- Thank you very much for
coming along this afternoon.
My name is Ian Robinson
and I'm a graph architect
with the Amazon Neptune service team.
And I'm very pleased to be
joined today by Evan Erwee.
who's an AVP for cyber
operations at Deloitte.
In this session, we're
gonna be talking about some
of the work that the
Neptune team have been doing
to improve generative AI question
answering solutions using
GraphRAG techniques
and how Deloitte have used the
results of some of that work,
which is an open source Python
library called the GraphRAG
Toolkit, how Deloitte have
used the GraphRAG toolkit
to build their cybersecurity
intelligence center.
So our assumption here is that
you are familiar a little bit
with graphs and graph databases,
with vector similarity search and with RAG
or retrieval augmented
generation techniques.
So we're not going to go
into a lot of explaining
of those concepts or tools.
Instead, we're gonna be
looking more at how Deloitte
or the cybersecurity intelligence
center have applied them.
But before we get into those
details, I'm briefly just going
to sketch the overall problem
that Deloitte are trying
to solve here with the
Cybersecurity Intelligence Center.
So has anyone here used a
cloud security platform such
as Wiz or CrowdStrike?
Okay, we've got a few hands.
So if you use such a platform,
something very interesting
happens the first time you switch
it on, the first time you
enable it in your environment.
As one of Evan's colleagues likes to say,
the whole Christmas tree lights up,
suddenly hundreds, possibly
thousands of alerts
or non-compliance notifications.
So now having solved one problem that
of identifying potential
security risks in your cloud
infrastructure, your SecOps engineers
and analysts are faced with another,
how can they remediate
these issues in a safe
and timely fashion, okay?
And it's not simply a
matter of automating fixes.
I mean, platforms like Wiz
already allow you to do that.
I mean, given the number of issues
and the complexity of
production environments
and the possibly punishing timelines
for fixing known issues, you know,
particularly if you're
in a regulated industry,
then these SecOps engineers
are going to have to triage
and prioritize and they're
going to have to prioritize
on at least two factors.
The first is they need
to understand each issue
or the serious or the significance
of an issue in the context
of your organization's
cybersecurity policies.
And second, they're going to need
to understand the likely impact
of any remediation on
existing production systems.
And there's no one size
fits all solution here.
You know, your cybersecurity policies
and your production systems are particular
to your organizations.
So you're going to need a lot
of organization specific
knowledge in order to be able
to make these informed decisions,
to be able to prioritize
and then remediate.
So the SecOps engineers
are the real experts here,
but given the size of the challenge,
they'll likely benefit from
some expert assistance.
So on the one hand, it's a simple problem
of information overload.
So automation can help, you
can improve the flow of work
by automating common tasks,
but more importantly,
it's a context problem.
These engineers, before they
can make an informed decision,
they need to understand each
issue in its organizational
context and that context
can comprise lots and lots
of different things,
lots of formal knowledge,
lots of tribal or informal knowledge.
So things such as the
cybersecurity policies, run books,
best practices, architectural guidance,
and even the current state
of those production systems.
So automation and context,
that sounds a lot like generative AI.
So given the title of the talk,
you probably won't be surprised
to learn that we think
that generative AI and RAG
or retrieval augmented
generation has a large
part to play in the solution.
So later in the session, Evan
is going to be discussing AI
for triage, which is an
expert in the middle AI
assistance for SecOps engineers.
Effectively, it's closing
the loop between a platform
such as Wiz identifying an issue
and an engineer being responsible
for applying a remediation
back to production systems.
And in building AI for triage,
Deloitte have used the GraphRAG toolkit,
which is an open source Python library
developed by the Neptune team.
And AI for triage uses
the GraphRAG toolkit
to maintain this ever evolving
organizational knowledge
base, which comprises things
such as policy documents,
run books, architectural
guidance, and triage records.
So EAL will be talking about AI
for triage a little later on.
But before we talk about
that, I'm just going
to spend a little time talking
in a bit more detail about
some of the work that we've
done on the Neptune side
to improve GraphRAG techniques.
And I wanna start here by returning
to this issue of context.
RAG is all about context.
You know, we populate the context window
with relevant content
that we've retrieved from
some backend data sources,
and then the language model uses
that context in order
to generate a good
response to a user query.
But the kind of context that we retrieve
and the ways in which we
retrieve it can make a big
difference to the quality of the response
and the reliability of the response.
So I want to illustrate
this with a simple example.
Imagine we are responsible for
a large corpus of documents,
many thousands of documents,
things like press releases,
news articles, analyst reports,
and for this example that are five in
particular that were important to us.
The first is a news article
that discusses Example Corp
and its wonderful new widget product.
The second is an analyst
report that discusses the fact
that there's a potential large demand
for widgets in the run up
to Christmas in the UK.
The third is a press release that says
that Example Corp have partnered
with any company logistics in order
to reduce shipping times from Asia
where those widgets are
manufactured to Europe and the UK.
And then we've got another
press release that says
that any company logistics are now
using the Turquoise Canal.
It's a fictitious canal,
the Turquoise Canal,
to further reduce those
shipping times from
weeks down to days.
And then finally we have this
recent news article that says
that unfortunately the Turquoise
Canal is currently shut
because of an ongoing large
scale cybersecurity incident.
So we've got five articles,
many thousands of other
documents and so on.
Now imagine you are an analyst tasked
with investigating the
fortunes of Example Corp,
and you've decided to
use a RAG application
to help with your research.
So here's one of the
questions you might ask.
"What are the sales prospects,
for Example Corp in the UK?"
Now, in order to answer this,
the system is going to have
to retrieve some context from
that corpus of documents.
One way of retrieving context is
to use vector similarity search.
We can use similarity
search to find content
that is semantically similar
to the question being asked.
And in this case it's gonna be content
that likely mentions Example Corp,
an Example Corp in relation to the UK.
So something like this,
these top three articles.
So we retrieve that context
and given that evidence,
the system can then reply,
"Hey, sales prospects are
great, they're really up"
and on the surface that looks
like a good response given
that evidence, that looks
like a good response.
But we as omniscient
observers of that corpus
of documents know that it's not
necessarily the whole story,
that there's a more nuanced answer
that we could give to that question.
But in order to produce a
more reliable answer, we need
to retrieve content that's
not only semantically similar
to the question, but we need
to retrieve some additional
structurally relevant,
potentially dissimilar content.
And I say structurally relevant
because we can perceive
some structure here.
There is a connection between Example Corp
and any company logistics and
between any company logistics
and the Turquoise Canal and
between the Turquoise Canal
and this ongoing cybersecurity incident.
But if we can retrieve both
of these kinds of content,
then the system can give
us a more nuanced answer.
"Yep, sales are looking good,
but they're likely to
be negatively impacted
by an ongoing cybersecurity incident."
Okay, so as you can see the
kind of context we retrieve
and the ways in which we
retrieve it can make a big
difference to the quality
and the reliability of the response.
In RAG terms, this is all
about improving recall.
Recall's the percentage
of relevant content
that a system retrieves in
response to a user query.
So based on that example,
we might say that in order
to improve recall, we need to
be able to retrieve content
that is similar to the
question being asked
and content that is structurally relevant
but potentially dissimilar
to the question being asked.
One way of retrieving that content is
to employ a hybrid RAG approach.
So with hybrid RAG, we
use vector search to find
that semantically similar content
and graph search to find
the structurally relevant
but potentially dissimilar content.
So hybrid RAG can be pretty effective,
but once again, we're in this situation
where we solved one problem
but have potentially introduced another.
And the issue is that the
quality of a graph search
is very much dependent on the quality
of the underlying graph.
So if the structure of
the graph isn't aligned
with our information goals,
we can often end up retrieving misleading
or irrelevant content
and that's going to generate
a poor response, okay?
So these are the kind of approaches
and some of the issues that
we had in mind when we started
designing the GraphRAG toolkit.
And from the outset we set ourselves
two high level design goals.
The first was we wanted to
make it easy for you to be able
to build a graph from
your own unstructured
or semi-structured data sources
and with very little information
architecture overhead.
If any of you built a graph
application in the past,
you know, you may know there's
often a large information
architecture component to
designing a good graph model
that is aligned with
your information goals.
So we wanted to try and reduce
that information architecture
effort on your behalf.
The second goal was that we
wanted to help you find all of
that relevant but non-obvious or distant
or potentially dissimilar
content to make it easy for you
to find all of that
content without you having
to write complex graph queries, okay?
So how did we go about
addressing these two goals?
Well, the first was we want
to make it easy for you
to be able to build a graph
from your own unstructured
or semi-structured data sources.
And to be clear here, we're
talking about things like text
files, PDFs, mark down files,
but also things like CSV
files or Excel documents
or even JSON documents, but
primarily text-based content.
Well the first thing we
decided to do was to eliminate
that information architecture overhead.
Instead of you having to build a graph,
the toolkit builds a graph for you
and it builds a very
specific type of graph
with a very specific model,
something we call a
hierarchical lexical graph.
So you can think of this
lexical graph as a repository
of statements and a statement is a short,
well-formed standalone proposition
that we've extracted
from your source data.
And these statements form
the primary unit of context
that we're going to pass
to the language model
to generate a response.
So at retrieval time, our goal is
to retrieve highly relevant statements
and then we group them
thematically by topic
and we attribute them
back to their sources.
But it's the statements themselves
that really comprise the
primary unit of context
and that's what we're passing
to the language model in order
to generate a response.
So the statements are really at the heart
of this lexical graph model.
All of the other parts of
the model really have a role
or responsibility to make it easy
to find all of those relevant statements.
So every note type here has a job to play
at retrieval time in
making it easy to find all
of these relevant statements.
So at the top here in blue,
we have what we call the lineage tier.
So this comprises source
nodes and chunk nodes.
So the source nodes
represent source documents
and they contain metadata.
So at retrieval time we can
apply metadata filtering
and we can also use that
metadata for versioning.
If you re-index a document
that has changed since the
last time you indexed it,
we can add some metadata so
that we can identify
which version is current
and which are the historical versions.
And then you can query the graph
and say, "I'm interested in
the current state of the graph"
or "I'm interested in the state
of the graph at a
historical point in time."
So that's the source nodes.
Below them are the chunk nodes
and they represent chunked content.
And this is exactly the same kind
of chunk content you're going to get
with a traditional vector RAG application.
These chunks are also associated
with embeddings in the vector store.
So at retrieval time they act
as a vector-based entry
point into the graph.
If we do a similarity
search in the vector store,
we can use the results to then
find the corresponding chunk
nodes in the lexical graph.
And from there we can begin traversals
throughout the rest of the graph.
The middle tier here is
the summarization tier.
This comprises those
statements, those primary units
of context, statements
grouped thematically by topic
and supported by discrete facts.
And I'll talk about the role of topics
and facts in a bit more detail in moment.
And then at the bottom we have this entity
relationship tier.
So this comprises entities
and the relations between entities
that we've extracted
from your source data.
Now this entity relationship
tier helps us in further domain
semantics of the dataset,
but more importantly at retrieval
time it helps us find all
of that structurally relevant
but potentially dissimilar information.
And I'm going to explain how we do
that in a lot more
detail in a little while.
But just briefly back to topics and facts.
The topics act a thematically
group statements that belong
to the same source document.
So there's a kind of source chunk topic
and statement sub graph that represents
a single source document
and topics act a group statements
thematically belonging to
that single source document.
So in this way they provide
what we call a degree
of local connectivity.
They allow a graph search
or a graph traversal to
do a deep investigation
of thematically linked content belonging
to a single source document.
Facts on the other hand, can
connect multiple statements
and multiple statements
that are potentially drawn from
different source documents.
Okay, so in that respect,
the facts provide
for global connectivity.
We can allow a search
or a graph traversal to
conduct a broad investigation
of the corpus by way of
navigating across that fact layer.
So this is what the context
window actually looks
like at retrieval time.
This is what we're passing to the LLM.
As you can see it's sets of
statements grouped thematically
by topic and attributed
to an individual source.
So one of the key takeaways
here, and this applies whether
or not you're using the GraphRAG toolkit,
whether or not you're
actually doing GraphRAG,
but this responsibility based approach
to graph modeling I think is
a very powerful complement
to the traditional representation
based approach that we have.
So normally we think of a graph data model
as representing the things in our domain
that we're interested in,
but I'd suggest that there's
a kind of complementary way
of thinking about certain types of node.
They're there to help us find
the stuff that we're interested in.
It's not so matter much a matter of saying
to a node, what are you?
It's more like what can
you do for me, alright?
So that's the lexical graph,
a repository of statements,
we return statements in the
context windows to the LLM.
Other parts of that graph are there really
to help at retrieval time find
relevant sets of statements.
So our second design goal
was how can we make it easy
for you to be able to find all
of that relevant non-obvious,
potentially dissimilar content
and all without you having
to write graph queries.
Well, as I said earlier with hybrid RAG,
we use vector similarity
search to find content
that is similar to the
question being asked
and graph search defined content
that is structurally relevant
but potentially dissimilar.
But I also said that there
was a problem here in
that the quality of a graph
search is very much dependent on
the quality of the underlying graph.
So how can we mitigate this issue?
Well, one way is to redescribe
what it is we're trying
to achieve at this point in time.
So here's an alternative formulation.
In order to improve
recall, we need to be able
to find content that is similar
to the question being asked
and content that is similar
to something different from
the question being asked.
So that sounds a bit, you know,
it's like fancy word play,
it's a bit clunky, bit abstract.
But look what we've done.
We've taken what was previously
a vector search and a graph search
and we've turned it into two
separate similarity searches.
One for content that is similar
to the question being asked
and one for content that is
similar to something else.
So what we need is some kind of proxy
or representation
for something different from
the question being asked.
And that's exactly where
that entity relationship tier can help us.
So at retrieval time what
we do is find a number of
what we call entity network context.
And an entity network context is a one
or two hop network
surrounding key entities
and keywords that we've extracted from the
question that's being asked.
We then take these
entity network contexts,
we create textual transcriptions of them
and we use them throughout the rest
of the querying process in order
to find those relevant statements.
So that's the high level approach.
I'm now going to tell you exactly
how we go about generating
those entity network contexts
and then how we use
them throughout the rest
of the querying process.
So generating entity network contexts,
well we've got a user question,
what are the sales prospects
for Example Corp in the UK?
The first thing we do is
look up significant entities
and keywords from that question in
that entity relationship tier.
So we end up with a set
of candidate entity nodes,
we then re-rank those
nodes against the question.
So with that re-rank set of
nodes, we can now identify
what we consider to be
the most important entity.
We're still interested in
the entire candidate list,
but we're also interested in the one
that represents the most
important or significant entity.
And at this point we're
gonna make a note of the
degree centrality of that
most important entity.
We make a note of it because we're going
to use it in a little while.
Now we do some path expansion
and this is configurable,
but typically we expand
each candidate node,
one or two hops, okay?
So we're beginning to generate
those little entity network
contexts, one or two hop
networks surrounding each entity.
We then filter each entity
along each of those paths
and we filter based on a threshold
that's derived from the
degree centrality of
that most important entity.
Effectively what we're
trying to do at this point is
eliminate whales and minnows.
We're trying to eliminate nodes
that might completely
dominate the conversation
and nodes that are potentially
completely irrelevant okay?
So we filter along each entity path,
eliminating the whales and minnows.
We then rescore all the
nodes along each path,
calculate the mean score for each path,
and then we can reorder the paths based
on their mean scores, okay?
So now we've got a list of paths ordered
by their mean scores.
And then finally again, another
configuration parameter.
We live in that list.
Perhaps we're we're
interested in the top five,
the top three, okay.
So at that point we've got a list
of paths derived from these
entity network contexts
and we can create textual
transcriptions of those paths
and then use them throughout the rest
of the querying process.
So here we've got three paths
and what we'll find is that
as we go down that list,
we are introducing notes of dissimilarity.
So the first path is the
path that is most similar
to the question being asked,
but the paths that come
below introduce more
and more dissimilarity, okay?
So we then use these paths,
these entity network context
in three different ways
throughout the rest of
the querying process.
The first way is that we
use them to seed a series
of dissimilarity searches.
So this is the point at which
we are looking for content
that is similar to
something different from the
question being asked.
So we can do a vector
similarity search for each
of those entity network paths
and we can use the results
to then find corresponding chunk
nodes in the lexical graph.
And from there we can take
advantage of that local
and global connectivity in order to do
deep and broad traversals okay?
So we're doing a vector similarity search
that's then helping us find
those vector-based entry
points into the graph, those chunk nodes.
And from there we're
traversing the graph to try
and find the statements along those paths.
So again, all we're trying
to do is accumulate sets
of statements that we're going
to return in the results set.
The second way in which we use
these engine network context
is to actually re-rank the results.
So remember the results
comprise sets of statements.
So we've got a long list of statements.
We re-rank them using weighted
term frequency analysis.
We don't use a re-ranking model,
we use weighted term frequency analysis.
So we've got a list of candidate
statements that we found
through our graph reversals
and we create a set of match items.
So the match items comprise
the original question plus all
of those entity network
context in descending order.
And we weight those match items.
So the first two, the original question
and the first path have
the strongest weight
and then the weighting
descends from there on.
So then we can score each
statement against each match item,
calculate the mean score
for each statement,
and then reorder the statements
based on their mean score.
And what you'll see in this example is
that we've got statements that
mention any company logistics
and the Turquoise Canal
and they've been promoted
to close to the top
of the result set and they've
been promoted even though they
score very, very low for
the original question, okay?
But the reason they've been promoted is
because they score relatively highly
for those last two
entity network contexts,
the ones that mention
any company logistics
and the Turquoise Canal.
And then finally the third
way in which we use these
internet network context is to
enrich the prompt that we use
to generate a response.
So besides supplying the user question
and the search results,
we also add in this additional
context which comprises those
entity network contexts.
So we're effectively telling the LLM,
"Hey look, take advantage
of all these search results
but pay attention to these
bits of additional context."
We're effectively guiding the LLM
or instructing it to pay
attention to statements
that it might otherwise
skip over or ignore.
So it does all this work? Yes.
So if we use traditional
vector similarity search,
the kind of responses that we get
and remember we're also
getting chunk based context
that's being supplied to the LLM,
but the kind of response that we get,
lots and lots of detail.
But finally it's that
overly optimistic response.
Sales prospects appear
exceptionally strong.
But if we run the exact same question
with the GraphRAG toolkit,
we get all of that detail,
but then we get a more nuanced conclusion.
Potential supply chain challenges,
global distribution may face disruption or
because of a large scale cyber attack.
So this could create product shortages
and affect delivery times okay?
So another key takeaway
here is that graph search
and vector search are mutually
beneficial for our kind
of operation or our kind of use case.
Graph search is great at finding all of
that structurally relevant content,
but vector search is really
good at mitigating quality
issues in the original question
and in the underlying content.
So the two kind of work in concert
during the retrieval process in order
to smooth out any quality issues.
So that's the GraphRAG toolkit.
So a couple of resources here,
the toolkit itself is
an open source library.
There's a link here, a QR
code to the GitHub repository.
There's also a link here and a QR code
to a paper describing the
hierarchical lexical graph
in a lot more detail.
And that includes some of the results
that we generated towards the end
of last year when we started
some of this research.
The GraphRAG toolkit, you know,
employs a hybrid RAG approach,
but importantly it supports
multiple different backends.
So today on the graph side
we support Amazon Neptune,
Neptune Analytics, and Neo4j.
On the vector store side we
support Neptune Analytics again,
Amazon OpenSearch Serverless
and Postgres with the PG vector extension.
Key point is it's a library,
it's not a full-blown application.
It's intended that you
combine it with other tools,
other libraries in order
to build out more fully
featured applications.
And that's exactly what Deloitte
had done in employing it in
this cybersecurity intelligence center.
So at this point I'm going to
hand over to Evan who's going
to describe in more detail the
Cybersecurity Intelligence Center.
- Thank you very much.
Now what I'm gonna try, I'm
not gonna talk about Deloitte,
I'm pretty sure you not
here about a partner.
I want each of you to ground
in a couple of concepts.
The best way to do that is
to talk about us as a human
because we all understand how we work.
You've had the GraphRAG toolkit.
For a moment in time,
imagine that is your long-term memory
and I'm gonna focus on your working memory
and your short-term memory.
When we live and go through
about our daily lives,
there is no segregation between
those other than on paper.
We keep on building our long-term memory.
What I will demonstrate is a
problem we see often is that
to react, especially in cyber,
but with many other tools
only out of short-term memory
the here in and now.
And that becomes problematic
because what we cannot
establish is the true nature
of the problem across
your entire organization.
What we have in many
organizations is this dilemma,
what we call the zero disconnect dilemma.
It's a dichotomy, in one end,
you've got an organization
that wants to proverbially
and physically keep
things connected networks
or they wanna be in the know as far as
what they know about cyber threats.
But at the exact same time,
you've got perpetrators
who's doing the exact
same but opposite.
Imagine for a second you've
all been in these rooms
that instead of everybody
who works very, very hard
to get your microphones to
work, get them clean up,
get everything to be perfect.
Imagine some of us are rogue agents,
we seek out the best
possible way to disrupt,
we wear the same clothes,
we wear the same badges,
we don't know who we are.
Keep that idea in your mind.
That's the world of cybersecurity.
There's no friend or foe.
What we are dealing with is a continual
dichotomy of zero disconnect.
And that is how we in
Deloitte end up talking
to the AWS teams.
But our relationship,
we realize graph can help us on a journey
of zero disconnect.
Now what we've seen in many instances
for many organizations is this problem
where organizations are
somewhat disconnected
and they have defenses
in order to help them
to justify that.
They have this idea of well maybe
I've got a checkbox compliance.
I mean that, that's great,
isn't it? I've done my best.
Maybe it's optics driven, it looks good,
I've got the best tools,
I bought lots of them
and that tells me what's going on.
For us at the end of
the day, it comes back
to something which nobody
wants to talk about
and that's plausible deniability.
Surely if I've done enough
then nobody can tell me that
what I've done isn't good enough.
For us as an organization
and for all of you here, I'm a developer.
I know when I go to my
boss and say A and it's B,
I know that, I've been a
developer for many years.
The problem we had up till
now in our organization
and many of our clients was
we have got these SOC analysts
and they triage things.
No problem, you guys all do that.
And then they throw it
over the proverbial thanks
to the business who's merely an observer
and they make their own notes.
Now honestly, if these
notes are the same thing,
that's gonna be a miracle from
above because they're not.
What we wanted was a world, first,
our first step using the GraphRag toolkit,
building long-term memory
where we can take our lessons learned
in a triage record.
That's our experience.
It's not what the tools are
telling us but our experiences
and fit that back into
some form of factory to
where that becomes a central
repository for what's happening
as far as cybersecurity
in our organization
or in our clients' organization.
We realize the GraphRAG
tool, he can do exactly that.
It's really brilliant.
We've also realized that we have to keep
our triage record generated
by AI, separate, immutable.
Human arbitration are very important.
We have to be able to
state what was AI generated
and what was human generated.
It can never, never break that rule
because if we break that
rule, we make a decision.
It's not defensible afterwards.
We also realize that we've
got these folks that wants
to reason and reflex using
these triage records,
but we also realized that if
we can do this properly using
the toolkit, we can get
closer to our vision
of zero disconnect by
creating collaboration
between our analyst and
our business wherever
that business might be.
That was our vision. Can we do that?
The one thing we've learned
is that we are missing
short-term memory.
When we get these signals
and feeds from our systems
as far as our tooling,
those are not long-term memory.
Converted into a triage record
that is long-term memory,
but at the moment in time
those are just noise.
Those are the signals.
So we needed a document graph.
We built a document graph,
we add that to the GraphRag toolkit.
We built in such a way we
can build document graphs
into logical domains.
And that allows us to group
document centric information
from, for example, tools.
We gonna talk about Wiz
briefly in a second.
Wiz has got their own sort
of derived vocabulary.
So within that domain we
can have a shorten term
derived vocabulary.
We can have what we call
moderate entity resolution
because within the space,
for example the Wiz tool
or a Prisma, there's some form
of relationships inherently
that exist and it wouldn't be
taken too much energy to do.
Now again, I reiterate that
what we are aiming for is
to build a triage record,
which is the conversion
from our short-term memory
into our long-term memory.
It's a common mistake we see,
people think AI is all about
taking all my short-term
memory and react on that.
No, because it's going to miss the nuance
of your common experience.
So again, what did we
build? What did we see?
I think that I want all
of you to take away,
GraphRag is your knowledge corpus.
It is your experience just like
all of you, as you get older
of more and more experiences,
you want to capture
that experience in your
organization, you wanna retrieve it,
you wanna make sure
that's good experiences,
but at the same time you wanna curate
your short-term experiences,
your short-term memory
curated in a land which is understandable.
Otherwise you're going
to get lots and lots
and lots of information
in your long-term memory.
That's completely meaningless.
So what we done, we've
written a document graph,
which is our hard data.
We bring that hard data
to our analyst in a form
of a AI generated triage record.
We fade that back into the document graph
and we use that for
overarching contextual analysis
and that allows us to get a
picture of the organization,
not a picture of a lot of tools.
We do that with a man in the
middle, human in the loop,
whatever term you want to use
because we wanna make sure
that we are accountable
and the decision we make is
what we call human augmented decision
which means we basically put
an Iron Man suit on our people.
We don't book robots and
get rid of our people
because that wouldn't work.
There's a couple of things
we learned that we had to do.
We had to make sure with a
GraphRag tool we worked very
closely with AWS that we
can read from more sources
and we've added those more sources.
Jason was great but we
needed some other sources.
Well the short-term memory,
long-term, short-term,
we needed videos, audio and all of that.
We need multimodal embedding
so we worked a bit on that
and then we realized that
the biggest struggle is
how do we get this lots and lots of data
from these various tools
very quickly in a graph.
And as all of you wanna
become a graph expert,
none of our people want to do that.
So we've written a very,
very sophisticated pipeline
and the pipeline allowed us
and in the pipeline is embedded with AI
and Bedrock to build a mechanism
of turning any signal, log, chain apps,
whatever data we get into a JSON now
and then turn that rapidly
into our short-term memory.
Why? Lemme give you one example.
Let's say that we are interested
in a short-term experience
about a place we visit.
Now let's make it practical.
We get information in about an IP address.
An IP address is not a place
that we visited directly,
it's indirectly.
So for example, this pipeline
will take an IP address
and automatically convert into the ASA
in an actual location.
Because that's what I'm interested
in my short-term memory,
that's what I want to know.
So we wrote this pipeline
but we wrote in such a way
that the engine that reads
and an engine that writes
is two separate engines.
Why, because there's
a new concept beathing
inside of document graph.
There's very recent writings
which is called graph
pollution and that is an injection
of phantom data into a
graph in order to derail.
All of that, we build in here
to make sure we don't pollute
our short-term memory.
We also made a decision from the ground up
that we cannot expose the experience
of talking directly to these
AI world into applications.
It evolves too quickly.
There's too many moving parts.
So we created something called
a cognitive substrate to
where we have effectively
we call that a factory
or an AI enabled factory.
It's not an AI factory to
where the factory is your interface.
Behind it, encapsulated
shielded is the process to
where we have the triage
protocol, that's agentic AI,
the prompt set that we can
curate for that specific mining
of your short-term memory.
The document graph
which effectively built,
which captures your experience
from the particular tools,
maybe the signal or the
lock file coming in.
But we also always bring
back the lexical graph
because we always have to
bring back our long-term
experience 'cause it's an infinite loop.
We then take all of that
and we let our experts deal
directly with our factory.
That means we built a
factory in our organization
that is about the
organizational cyber experience
and encounters as opposed
to what a tool said.
Now how do we build this?
It was very important
for us first to build
or find a platform which
we deem is reliable.
We chose Amazon EKS,
it's a reliable platform
and we currently have 99.999949 uptime
and that's pretty stable.
We decided that we wanna make it narrow.
So we use Neptune in OpenSearch,
although the GraphRag tool
could do support other
databases, we opt for those.
It just makes it easier for us.
We standardize the Amazon
NOVA from the get go.
Just so in a POC, our
world is not too broad.
We've also bring in
SageMaker into the mix,
although we are not developing models yet.
But think about your long-term
memory becoming a model
one day because it's curated data,
it's not a tool data
and then our factory is
running on DynamoDB in S3.
S3 is to where I've got journaling.
So we can always play the
factory back if anything happens.
And then for any upload or
download into our environment,
we've used a AWS Lambda
and API Gateway,
CloudFront as well in order
to bring in documents.
There's a lot of other
sort of elements here
that I haven't spoke about,
but those are not relevant.
Those are the high level that we've used.
So let's look at it in
action very quickly.
We already spoke about the top,
our long-term memory and that stays there.
That's what be referenced.
In this case we have
worse and we're gonna go
through it very quickly with issues.
We switch on the sort of
Christmas tree phenomenon.
That's our facts. The query
gets pumped into the factory.
The factory makes a decision.
Have I seen this before?
I mean it's the common class of an issue,
encryption for example of an EBS volume.
I mean we might get dozens of issues.
Yeah, I've seen this before.
I'm gonna link it to an
existing triage record.
It's like when you go to a restaurant
and you ate something
you already had before,
there's nothing new, been there, done that
or now it's new experience,
something new I'm gonna generate.
It takes a record
and pumps it back into
our contextual artifacts.
It bolts our long-term memory all the time
because that is our price possession.
That's what makes our teams powerful.
So lemme give you a real issue
of taking an account, seven AWS domains.
We switch it on and within
just over a couple of weeks,
four weeks, 50,000 issues,
we run our pipeline.
We distilled 50,000
issues to just over 1,300
that's usable that we want
to investigate further.
Rapidly convert that into just over
six and a half thousand nodes
or automate it in just over 19,000
actual relationships.
We pump all of that data.
We call it the Wiz playbook,
which is an instance
of a triage record inside our factory
and it generates for us evidence
remediation and so forth.
In a JSON format
because ultimately we're gonna
pump the JSON format back.
We've taken that information, run it
through a report service so it can report,
our analyst can look at
it, they can annotate it,
they can reject it.
And based on the evidence we found,
we also create automation from that.
I'll talk about automation in a second.
Now, very important for automation.
What we've learned, and this
is a bit of a takeaway for all,
don't create automation
on code, libraries change,
there's vulnerabilities,
all that kind of things.
Create recipes for automation.
They are a lot more during
and durable than code.
Also very important,
any short-term memory,
whether you like it or not is historical.
So make sure you have this
idea of called check, do check.
So even if we find
something, we are gonna go
and check it again because
maybe what happened now
or we think happened
is no longer happening.
Okay? We built that into the recipe.
So we got an interpreter.
The interpreter for the
recipe is written by a human.
The recipe is written by
AI. Very important, okay?
We trust AI with a recipe not
so much for code when it comes
to large scale remediation.
At the end of the day, what
we have is a fully fledged
recipe that we can store
in a central repository
that is human reasonable.
And a great part is this goes
back into a long-term memory
'cause back into lexical graph,
which means over a period
of time we can make claims such as
what exactly is happening
in our organization?
What evidence have we
collected? What is the trend?
So why is that so important?
It is a first step to go
from operational reality
into policy intent.
Instead of writing policies
that has nothing to do
with your operational reality,
now we have a reality and
we can actually augment
our policies based on
what's really happening.
And these reports effectively
are installed centrally
and they can contain compliance.
They are class of report,
but they also, every individual issues are
linked to a report.
So think about a report or
as a class of experience
and every individual
issue as an instantiation
of that class.
So we can either transverse
in our memory on a particular
incident or an all incident
of a particular class in order
to understand what is happening.
Let's wait for a second. There we go.
So what does this mean?
It means for us that
we now have an ability
to do truth and traceability short-term,
fit that into a lexical,
take that, that becomes a
meaning of our understanding
for both our analyst and our business.
At any point in time,
we have an understanding
in our organization.
We no longer deal with
just a Christmas tree.
We no longer deal with an
application in each point
of view, we have our point of view.
Based on the GraphRag toolkit that corpus
of knowledge gets expanded, gets built.
And that is our, again, prized possession.
So can I hand back to
Ian to conclude for us?
Yeah, thank you.
- Okay, so we've learned quite a bit
about the AI for triage.
What I really like about
this use case is that we are
augmenting human expertise.
We're not trying to replace it
and we're augmenting it
with, as Evan describes it,
this long-lived evolving memory, okay?
And in order to provide those
experts with that memory,
we need to have improved
recall within the systems
that we're using to serve up that memory.
And that's really where that GraphRAG
toolkit comes into play.
And I've tried to describe
some of the techniques
that we've applied on
the Neptune side in order
to provide those capabilities.
The graph model itself,
which is structured all
around the statements,
returning relevant statements,
which would effectively
comprise my particular memory
at this moment in time.
And the query techniques that
we've introduced, particularly
around entity network
contexts that can help us
find all of that structurally relevant
but potentially dissimilar information
that is super important when you're trying
to reconstruct a deep
understanding of an issue.
So there's a lot that we
haven't talked about here in
terms of the GraphRAG toolkit.
A lot of additional
features I mentioned earlier
that it supports multiple
different backends.
It supports multi-tenancy.
So this is the idea that
you can have discreet
or separate lexical graphs
and the associated indexes in the same
underlying infrastructure.
I can have multiple different
lexical graphs in the
same graph database.
It supports document versioning.
So I can re-index
documents that have changed
and then I can query the graph
either for the current state,
the current documents or
the state of the graph
and state of specific
documents at a point in time.
We also provide the ability
to surface domain specific agentic tools
to an MCP server for example.
So we can take all of those
discreet lexical graphs,
we can automatically
infer the domain semantics
for each graph.
We can use that to produce
a tool description,
which we can then
advertise to an MCP server.
So now we've created a
capability for an agent
to query across different domains
and answer very, very complex questions.
And then finally we have a
separate module within the
repository called BYOKG.
Bring your own knowledge graph.
So what I've described
today is the ability
to create a graph from
unstructured data and to query it.
BYKOG allows you to bring
an existing graph in Neptune
or Neptune Analytics
and again, perform
question answering over it.
Things that we've got coming up next.
Well, we've always welcomed
contributions from the community.
Deloitte have contributed
already quite a bit
into the repository.
Over the next few months we
plan to move more of some
of the stuff that Evan has described.
Things in particular that
like the document graph,
bringing that into the repository.
We're always taking
requests from customers that
they discover new features or new needs.
We try and add those into the thing.
At the moment we're working on
several different additional
vector store backends that
we'll support in the GraphRAG
toolkit over the next couple of months.
Okay, over the next couple of days,
a couple of other graph talks.
Tomorrow we have the last
of three builders workshops,
which are all about
building an application,
a GraphRAG application
using the GraphRAG toolkit.
We ran one at the beginning
of the week, one this morning.
We've got our last hour long one
tomorrow in the Mandalay Bay.
And then on Friday a very
distinguished colleague,
Ora Lassila is talking about
symbolic AI in the age of LLMs
and he'll be here in Caesar's forum.
Okay, well thank you very
much for coming along today.
Thank you for listening and I
hope you have a great re:Invent.
Thank you.
(crowd applauds)